robed figures with hidden faces stand
over seven young women tied up the robed
figures chant phrases both Arcane and
profane the leader amongst these dark
cultists clears his Wicked throat and
says Be not Afraid girls you are here
for something wonderful do we get seven
perfect children for the Scarlet King
how did we get here and more importantly
what happened afterward in the near
constant darkness that follows the Grim
but necessary work of the SCP Foundation
there is one bright light that can
always be counted on to keep hope alive
to bring a little sunshine into
everyone's days
scp-999 the Tickle Monster the sweet
simple creature does nothing but provide
an endless source of Joy hugging playing
and delighting and loving everything
around it but what if I told you that
this slimy little friend has hidden
depths a tragic history that seems
impossible to reconcile with the happy
playful B being we all know and love how
could 999 the happiest SCP ever have a
sad backstory well it's one of the best
kept secrets at the foundation before we
get to that let's talk about a
foundation researcher and her brand new
job a new job that would make her privy
to some highly classified Foundation
Secrets Dr Izzy Collingwood was
delighted to wake up to a call informing
her that she had been appointed to one
of the most coveted positions at the SCP
Foundation after applying Crossing her
fingers and hoping for the best she had
been promoted to head researcher for
scp-999 what could be better than
attending to the kindest gentlest cutest
anomaly in Foundation custody gone were
the days of coming into work and
wondering if she'd leave in one piece no
more cleaning up toxic spills fighting
to contain killer creatures or fetching
cups of coffee for old doctors that
wouldn't give her so much as a thank you
years of hard work had paid off now she
could rest on her Laurels and do work
that she truly enjoyed there was just a
matter of some simple paperwork and she
would be ready to begin this extremely
welcome new chapter of her professional
life when she walked into her office to
get started on the paperwork something
unusual caught her eye there was a small
stack of files on her desk with a sticky
note attached to the front there were
just two words written on the note to
indicate what might await her inside the
folders the truth she scoffed at first
very funny guys she called out the door
but no one responded no one came forward
to take credit for the elaborate joke
maybe they were playing the long game or
maybe she couldn't be sure she sat down
flipping the first folder open it was
Untitled unlabeled just plain text on a
page she almost closed it after a brief
scan but the words the Scarlet King
jumped out at her she had worked at the
foundation long enough to hear that name
more than a few times often spoken in
tones as if merely speaking his name
would bring about some kind of disaster
as she dug deeper into the file she
realized just what she was looking at
the proposed origins of the Scarlet King
himself it was a folkloric explanation
one her scientific mind struggled to
wrap around but she had seen so many
strange things over the years things
that defied all rational explanation
perhaps there was some truth to be found
in the myths the Scarlet King had
according to the file once been an elder
god born from the earliest days of
existence in the shadows of the tree of
knowledge he had devoured his brothers
and sisters growing stronger with each
one he consumed as his strength
increased so too did his overwhelming
pain and hate his deep desire to destroy
the tree of knowledge and all living
creatures he declared himself the king
of darkness and through a series of
horrific events took seven unwilling
brides and bound them to him with
magical seals each bride bore
Supernatural children powerful terrible
and monstrous the first bride actic had
only a few children those few were
skilled strategists exceptionally wise
in the ways of war the second bride was
icor overcome with constant Despair and
desolation her children conquered with
massive unthinking armies never sated
and never quelled the third bride
aristot hated her sisters and all she
surveyed the fourth bride azib took the
shape of a great Beast her children
followed in her Steed and were
invulnerable their thick hides
impenetrable by physical or magical
means the fifth bride was unhut blessed
with a strong mind and cursed with a
fragile body her children were gifted in
the ways of magic and Incredibly
destructive the sixth bride atilif would
not speak she kept to herself and like
her her children moved in silent Islands
disguising themselves as whatever they
wished the seventh bride however was
different ahabat was her name the
smallest of the seven with an unbroken
Spirit she birthed Mighty Heroes that
she trained in secret in hopes that one
day they would overcome her family's
darkness and topple the king from his
throne all the while the Scarlet King
wages his Unholy war against all things
waiting for the day he can arrive in our
realm and unleash absolute destruction
Dr Collingwood shuttered as she finished
reading an undeniable chill passing over
her this definitely wasn't some kind of
prank or hazing ritual this was
something dark something real she held
secrets in her hands and she couldn't
stop reading them now she opened the
next folder it was a description of a
cult monitored and raided by the SCP
Foundation called the children of the
Scarlet King also known as group Mendes
during a 16-month investigation of the
homeless religious group the
foundation's undercover operatives were
able to ascertain a great deal of
pertinent information on the group what
they found was troubling and of great
concern the group had ties to several
wealthy benefactors as well as links to
extremist paranormal groups their set of
beliefs was relatively simple and
disturbing they worshiped the Scarlet
King and were devoted to supporting him
in his battle to destroy the Earth and
all Life As We Knew It the faithful who
followed him in this task would be
rewarded handsomely with positions of
power in this new hellish World an
initial estimate put the cult's
membership at approximately 8 000
members a quarter of whom belonged to
the group's primary branch in Alabama
the reporting on the cult was detailed
far too dense and heavily researched to
be fake again she had the distinct
feeling that someone was trying to tip
her off about something the foundation
hadn't wanted to be widespread knowledge
with shaky hands she picked up the final
file what awaited her inside there was
only one way to find out she flipped it
open and began to read it was a file on
an entity known as scp-231 specifically
scp-231-7 an addendum was attached to
the beginning of the file reading all
Personnel assigned to
scp-231-7 must rotate out for one month
of psychological counseling after two
months on site
scp-231-7 is to be kept at an
undisclosed location all Personnel
assigned to scp-231 will be transported
there blindfolded from site 19 by Route
including no fewer than seven different
forms of transportation including but
not limited to aircraft automobile
underground tunnel and several we cannot
discuss here removal of the blindfold
during the transport process is grounds
for immediate termination Personnel
assigned to
scp-231-7 must undergo heavy
psychological testing before being
cleared to enter or the site individuals
must score at least 72 points on the
milligram obedience examination be
unmarried have no Offspring and express
nothing less than total loyalty to the
foundation normal psychological
screening procedures against access to
disorders are waived so long as the
class D Personnel in question has the
mental capacity to carry out procedure
110 Montauk as needed Personnel who
Express sympathy towards
scp-231-7's plight and or Express a
desire to rescue or sympathize towards
scp-231-7 will be transferred to another
project without delay any actual rescue
attempts will be met with immediate
termination Personnel who have served on
the staff of
scp-231-7's containment team are not
required to divulge that information to
others no official record shall be kept
in the names of any staff assigned to
scp-231-7 Norwell said service appear in
the Personnel files of said staff while
on site individuals assigned to SCP
231-7 will be issued concealing helmets
with integrated voice changers to
protect their identity on-site staff are
not to remove said uniforms in the
presence of other staff members off duty
hours are to be spent in private
quarters Alone six class D Personnel are
to be assigned to
scp-231-7 each month for the purposes of
carrying out procedure 110 Montauk
violent criminals are not to be used for
this purpose due to the possibility of
accidental fatality during the 110
Montauk process Dr Collingwood swallowed
the lump of dread in her throat her
Palms beginning to sweat
scp-231-7 was a young woman retrieved
during a police raid on a warehouse
owned by the children of the Scarlet
King she was one of seven women found
there the first of which went into labor
24 hours after being rescued she did not
give birth to an ordinary child however
she gave birth to a monster that took
the lives of dozens of civilians did not
survive the birth the second woman was
lost shortly after also succumbing to
the dangers of the creature waiting to
be born from a womb one by one the
survivors the women chosen by this cult
to become the new bride of the Scarlet
King fell soon enough there was only one
left
scp-231-7 kept contained at a foundation
site in a hospital bed that she could
never leave Dr collingwood's stomach
churned as horrible images flooded her
mind the notes from attending
researchers in scp-231's file insisted
they were doing all they could to save
the woman to free her from her fate but
that there was little they could do each
birth opened a Gateway from this world
to another to a world of darkness and
despair and they could not allow the
final seal to be broken simply putting
the woman out of her misery would cause
the effect to jump to a new host a new
bride there was nothing to be done the
file fell from Dr collingwood's hand as
she pushed herself to her feet running
out into the hallway who put these on my
desk she shouted her voice echoing down
the empty Hall well what do you want
from me but no answer came slowly she
returned to her office and sank down
into her chair haunted by what she had
read she had seen horrific things in her
time at the foundation but nothing that
had shaken her to her core quite like
this the silence in Dr collingwood's
office was broken by the sound of a
tinny beep coming from her computer she
turned on the screen and saw the source
of the alert one new message from o5
command what could they possibly have to
say to her could it have something to do
with the files that had wound up on her
desk she accepted the message quickly
completed the mandatory multimodal
biometric ID scan and began to read
hello Dr Collingwood and congratulations
on your new appointment as scp-9999's
head researcher one of the cushiest and
most enviable assignments in the entire
Foundation
scp-999 is one of the few anomalies in
our custody who will not only never
attempt to harm you but will actively
try to save your life if you're ever in
danger though your initial reaction when
receiving this assignment was no doubt
Elation you may have thought it was odd
that such a seemingly low risk position
was assigned by the o5 council directly
if you had already heard rumors of this
prior to your assignment you probably
thought it was mere nepotism the o5s
protecting their friends and loved ones
by giving them the safest job possible
Dr Collingwood sat back in her chair
laughing to herself and shaking her head
she would never admit it but she
absolutely had heard those rumors even
believe them until it happened to her
unless you are so narcissistic to think
that someone on the o5 council must be
your secret admirer you've likely
realized that this is not the case to
understand why this is our concern you
need to know about
scp-9999's Origins you may have noticed
that its file makes no mention of where
it was discovered this is a deliberate
Mission if you are not familiar with the
mythology of the Scarlet King I suggest
you read up on him there's plenty of
unclassified information on him in the
foundation database all that's relevant
for now is that he is to the best of our
knowledge the most powerful malevolent
entity in the Multiverse her stomach
dropped At The Mention Of The Scarlet
King she was right this was all
connected somehow she leaned forward
eyes starting across the words with
increasing intensity as she read on
you've been with us since you were a
research assistant Dr Collingwood in
that time I assume you've heard many
rumors about some of the horrific things
we do here at the foundation that you've
probably never personally witnessed I
regret to inform you that these rumors
are true or at least they were a
pharmaturgical cult calling itself the
children of the Scarlet King enacted a
ritual wherein seven young girls became
Effigies for each of the Scarlet King's
Seven Brides allowing them to bear his
horrid Offspring how they obtain gain
the knowledge to perform this ritual is
unclear since all we ever recovered were
handwritten notebooks superficial
resemblances to some psychic practices
has led to some speculate that the
children of the Scarlet King may have
some ties to Modern psychic Cults it is
an interesting idea but no concrete
evidence has ever been found to link the
two investigation into the matter is
ongoing as for the ritual itself each
birth caused more destruction than the
last the writings of the cult's priest
predicted nothing less than the
apocalypse if the seventh bride gave
birth which could only be prevented if
procedure 110 Montauk was performed
without fail each and every day to our
seemingly great Fortune The Notebook
contained detailed instructions on how
110 Montauk was to be carried out
needless to say we found this
suspiciously convenient why would they
devise countermeasures to prevent the
very apocalypse they were trying to
invoke we needed more in information
regarding these entities fortunately our
archaeologists have Unearthed numerous
tablets Scrolls and artifacts on the
ancient Davos they were a sadistic and
warmongering people who were granted
Unholy power and knowledge by the
Scarlet King as a result for the death
and suffering they caused one of the
David tablets in our possession found
covered in dust and blood was a theogony
for the Scarlet King and his Brides it
was quite informative the information
that we found most relevant to our
situation was that the seventh bride was
not like her sisters she was never
completely broken by her King's
subjugation instead of monsters she gave
birth to Great heroes in the hopes that
they would destroy her sister's children
and overthrow their father thus far all
have failed but by a vote of seven in
favor six against admittedly more out of
concern for procedure 110 montauk's lack
of viability as a long term containment
strategy than out of empathy for the
girl the o5 council decided to believe
that the seventh bride still remained
unbroken and that her child would be an
asset to us at the risk of causing an XK
Class end of the world scenario
scp-231-7 was relieved from procedure
110 Montauk following the deaths of
scp-231-16 and was allowed to give birth
scp-999 was the result Dr Collingwood
gasped her hand flying to her mouth a
research assistant walking by her office
paused looked at her curiously through
the window she waved them off with a
forced smile and turned back to the
screen surely she couldn't have read
that correctly but no there it was plain
as can be go ahead and read that again
be sure you understand it in all its
Preposterous Ridiculousness the Tickle
Monster is the child of the Scarlet King
we've been running a
counter-intelligence campaign ever since
which is why everyone and their mother
thinks we've still got a girl strapped
to a rack in a bunker somewhere let them
think that far better for everyone that
the children of the Scarlet King believe
that they're playing us for fools than
for them to know that there is a threat
to their King the girl herself is fine
by the way she was cured of the trauma
from her ordealed buying scp-999 at
which point it was decided she could be
returned to her family so long as they
were all given class F and nestics
implanted with new identities and
relocated to a town at least one
thousand kilometers away from the
children of the Scarlet King's nearest
known activity on the insistence of the
Ethics Committee the family was also
given a seven-figure payout as
compensation for our repeated misdeeds
against their daughter as well as the
families of the other
scp-231s I suppose it was technically
malpractice on our part in case we have
any moles for the children of the
Scarlet King in the foundation as far as
anyone else knows 231-7's Family were
killed in front of her as part of 110
Montauk I'm sure you're skeptical are we
insane how could our sweet little Tickle
Monster ever hope to Dethrone a
lovecraftian horror of unparalleled
might well scp-999 is less than a decade
old it is still just a child and nowhere
near its full strength even so its power
is incredible even brief interaction
with scp-999 can permanently cure severe
depression and PTSD and more recent
experiments have resulted in the
complete Reformation of d-class
personnel who were previously
unrepentant sociopaths this effect is
not chemical but psychic and one day it
may grow powerful enough that not even
the Scarlet King himself will be immune
the experiment with scp-682 was most
remarkable based on multiple Davide
texts including descriptions from
scp-140 itself we are reasonably certain
that 6 City 2 is The Offspring of the
fourth Scarlet bride if this is true
then scp-999 is already strong enough to
temporarily quell the malevolence of its
own Eldritch siblings one day 999 could
very well be strong enough to
permanently reform its family members
just as it reforms human beings it will
not overthrow the Scarlet King by force
but with light and love and laughter
that can brighten the blackest of Hearts
999 is not in reality a safe class SCP
it is Formula it is the best and really
the only weapon we have against some of
the most powerful hostile entities known
to exist by all means doctor enjoy the
relative safety of your new position but
do keep in mind that scp-999 is not a
mere pet that we fancy it is one of our
most valuable assets and must be
safeguarded at all costs its safety and
well-being are Paramount and you are not
at Liberty to share this information to
anyone without level 5 5 or 999 security
clearance as per protocol an authorized
disclosure of level 5 classified
information will result in your
termination this email will
automatically delete as soon as you
leave the terminal so feel free to
reread it as many times as necessary to
remember all the pertinent information
take good care of our little Tickle
Monster the fate of the Multiverse May
well depend on it your secret admirer if
anyone asks 05-1 Dr Collingwood let out
a long slow breath as her mind did its
best to process everything she just read
the message looked official and when she
really thought about it this all made a
twisted kind of sense what could scp-999
possibly be if not some sort of Mythic
hero of divine prophecy what other
explanation could there be for something
so utterly perfectly good maybe one day
that happy little orange slime would
save them all and do it with a smile but
for now it was just a little innocent
child no need to burden with talk of
heroism of epic battles between good and
evil for now she would just pour scp-999
a heaping bowl of M Ms give it a gentle
pet and say thank you the Tickle Monster
gurgled excitedly in response nuzzling
his new head researcher's hand he didn't
understand what she was thanking him for
but he appreciated it all the same now
go check out scp-999 Tickle Monster
versus the most evilest CPS and what
does scp-999 do all day hour by hour for
more knowledge about the most adorable
anomaly of all